du côté d'europe écologie les verts
l'idée de se regrouper autour d'un
principe de désobéissance européenne
quand c'est nécessaire pour pouvoir
appliquer notre programme n'est pas un
sujet qui les rebute et ils sont je
crois sensible à cette discussion la
france insoumise veut faire de la
désobéissance européenne c'est-à-dire ne
pas appliquer les lois européennes
à chaque fois et bien que ça gêne son
programme alors la désobéissance
possible pour bat
la france un soumise par la voix du
directeur de campagne de jean luc
mélenchon le député européen manuel dont
part de même que la députée européenne
manon aubry veulent ne pas appliquer
certaines valeurs européennes par
exemple pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre la
transition écologique financer milieu
les services publics ou alors faire les
réformes sociales voulues par le
programme insoumis sauf que il n'est pas
certain que les lois européennes empêche
réellement un tout ce programme d'être
réalisé mais ça c'est une autre question
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose d'héroïque de
révolutionnaire a parlé de désobéissance
cela fait référence évidemment à la
désobéissance civile
la résistance à l'oppression qui
pourrait être contre on en trouve même
une expression dans la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen de 1789
qui proclame en son article 2 que la
résistance à l'oppression est un droit
naturel et imprescriptible
mais dans notre droit à la résistance à
l'oppression est plus une exigence
morale qu'un droit véritable dont on
pourrait se saisir sans se mettre en
infraction les faucheurs volontaires de
champs de cultures ogm ont été condamnés
par la justice de même que ceux des
gilets jaunes qui avaient enfreint la
loi ou encore les commandos anti ivg qui
bloque les cliniques pratiquant
l'avortement
[Musique]
au niveau européen c'est la même chose
il n'est pas possible de désobéir à la
loi européenne sans se mettre en
infraction avec elle et comme pour la
loi française vient d'être condamné pour
ça c'est ce qui est arrivé à la pologne
qui refusent de rétablir l'indépendance
de sa justice à la botte du gouvernement
et qui pour cela écope d'une amende de 1
million d'euros par jour tant qu' elle
ne sera pas conformé au droit européen
et ce sera pareil pour un gouvernement
la france un saut mise il exposera la
france à des amendes pouvant aller à
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
et si la france ne paie pas et bien la
commission européenne pourra suspendre
le versement de subventions pour les
français en d'autres termes ça sera
l'arroseur arrosé
[Musique]